members of the committee I'm going to
open up this executive session on Senate
Bill 258 and Senate Bill 228 but I'm
going to after I pass make sure an
amendment to 228 is distributed that
representative Eaton uh drafted but he
representative Eaton unfortunately he's
not here today any uh representative
Chris Schultz is filling in for him I'm
going to have this passed out and then
I'm going to have the committee
immediately recess and wait for the
chair uh who uh is running a little late
but wants to be here and I fully agree
with that so I'm going to start passing
out the amendment and while we're
waiting for the share if you want to
take a look at it but now I'm going to
recess this executive session uh until
uh till the chair arrives thank you
uh good morning to my committee and my
apologies
I had some business uh dealings this
morning I just couldn't get out of but I
wanted to be here so I sincerely
apologize to the committee first and
then the members of the audience uh for
my tardiness this doesn't happen very
often and I do apologize
so I want to thank the vice chairman
representative Cloutier for opening and
recessing I'm going to change the order
of where we're going to go I'd like to
start with um Senate bill
[Music]
um
to
yeah the Hilton ramp
and I believe that um the members
committee members have an amendment that
uh started out as representative Eaton
on on this matter
um I will bring you up to discussions
I've had
with uh
Commissioners and or directors
I spoke with the peas Authority
about this and making sure that there
was a willingness to be a part of this
study and if they were in agreement if
uh not only to be a part of it but
possibly to help facilitate part of it
and they were
I spoke to the director from Fish and
Game and he told me of the initial
hesitance in the beginning
of taking
um taking the project on and some of the
restrictions that might come from that
in that they might have to enforce
people parking and going in and out of
the water and then there was a question
of whether commercial
fishermen could use that ramp also so
they welcomed the idea of
working through a study with DOT them
and P's authority to make sure that they
could work that out and they were they
were more than happy then to engage in
the process
we have heard for a number of years
about the uh commercial oyster operation
that is started in that bay I I for some
reason thought that was happening
elsewhere but there's a lot of activity
there
and
we have
we have been
supportive of monitoring
quality of the water and so forth for
that purpose so I believe that makes
sense so
um with my ramblings
I would like to open it up for any
further discussion
um on the Eaton Amendment
yes uh I would like to make a motion to
move ought to pass on representative's
Amendment which is number uh 2023-1462h
thank you motion made and seconded by uh
vallone
um
any discussion
hearing yes representative staffy
I just read the two but I can't see the
difference
representative do you have uh okay um I
just I I strongly support this amendment
I think representative Eaton did a
fantastic job drafting I'm just sorry
he's not able to be here today but he
had a more important engagement I think
it really clears up a lot of everything
and I think it will make the the study a
lot easier and it does have a date in
there June 30th so the study will be
completed we'll take it up I mean the
report will be issued my guess is it's
probably we will have to take it up as
maybe in a capital appropriation in the
next capital budget if I had to guess
but it's a start anyway and I applaud
this amendment I'm in strong support of
it thank you
uh thank you I think the member's
question was about why we have two
copies of the same Amendment they are
identical yeah okay there was a mistake
sorry about that but that's uh two
copies just in case
and the confusion of that so you're
you're looking at the exact same
Amendment representative and I had asked
our assistant to uh to print a copy and
there was already a copy out here so I'm
afraid that's why you see two of the
same
and I believe the difference there there
wasn't a lot of definition of who was
going to be in the committee and how it
was to proceed and representative Beaton
had spent some time going and back and
forth uh between the sponsors and and
trying to get some accountability yes
representative I think one of the other
things that's been corrected is the
analysis that used to refer to
building a boat ramp and I now correctly
refers to the study I think as a another
thing that changed since the last time
we saw this and I do appreciate your
attention to detail thank you sir
further yes yes thank you Mr chairman
um one of the main differences I saw
from the original bill
was uh
on uh
page 11 of the original bill that said
representatives of the aquaculture
industry that's been taken out
of the new Amendment that's the basic
change I saw the question I had is I I
thought we heard a testimony saying that
the fishing game was saying no way that
the study should be could be completed
by June 30th 2024. has that been changed
thank you representative Newton the when
I spoke when I spoke to the director
last week from Fish and Game
um he said that
um he and his Department had thoroughly
reviewed it and that he was in favor of
what was written
yes please
um thank you for taking my question
um
also in the original bill they talked
about the pricing and how they would
lower the price below market value and
then have to accept it that's that's the
other Bill we're going to uh discuss
this was on the Dover property with the
boat I apologize you're correct I don't
normally get a chance to have that
conversation with you so thank you sir
further
so so we have a um we have a motion and
it has been seconded to prove uh
amendment to S Bill 228 FN
um I see as number 1462h
if you're in favor of that motion you'll
signify
um by when the we should do roll call I
apologize uh when when the role is
called you'll signify by saying aye if
you're opposed it'll be nay and with
that the clerk will call the roll
thank you Mr chair
representative Cloutier yes
representative Mills says yes
representative fadolfi
representative Newton yeah
representative Kaczynski
representative Bowden
representative
Boyd is not here representative Melvin
yes
representative bogert
representative Connor yes
representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar hi
representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes
and please beg my forgiveness I did not
get our substitute's name here not a
problem it's representative Schultz
a c-h-u-l-t-z
thank you representative Schultz
oh yes
representative Peterson
is not here
representative vallone yes
representative Juris yes
chairman McConkey chairman bowtie
Mr chair the motion passes 18 to zero
thank you
represent Schultz I apologize for not
recognizing you for sitting and uh I
want to be the probably the fourth
person at this point to welcome you to
Public Works and highways
all right so that will um
amend that so we voted on the amendment
that was a vote on the amendment they'll
write not the bill correct okay so this
is what would be ought to pass
all right motion okay I will make a
motion Mr chair of ought to pass with
Amendment on Senate Bill 228
motion made second and once against by
blown
um
the unanimous vote do you mind going
with a Voice vote
you can't okay sounds good the clerk
will call the roll
when you're ready sir
thank you Mr chair representative
Cloutier yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative adolfi yes
yes
representative Newton yes representative
Kaczynski
representative Bowden
representative Melvin yes representative
Bogart
yes
representative Connors
representative Jack yes representative
Abbott yes
representative Edgar
aye
representative Faulkner
representative Newman yes
representative Schultz yes
representative vallone yes
representative Juris yes
chairman McConkey yes
Mr chair the motion passes 18-0
the bill the bill has an FN on it it was
not due as an early note and I do not
believe it shows a um
a financial burden with the bill so with
that is their opposition to putting it
if possible on the consent calendar
seeing none we will put it on the
consent calendar
and
um I would like to
um
hold for five minutes and then we will
open up uh Senate bill 258.
will be recessed for five minutes I want
to speak to the Department
and the other people there
okay
thank you
come out of recess
and we will now work on the executive
session for Senate bill 258.
and before I do I know we have members
in the audience dot is here and I
believe some of the good folks from the
Historical Society are here that have
interest in this
executive session is is for the
deliberation of the committee
and rare exception will I open that up
for Testimony outside but I I welcome
and thank you for being here
before I do that I want to remind the
committee if you could stay afterwards
for just a couple extra minutes while I
have a card that I would like to ask
your Indulgence for a signature for
Lindsay we'll handle that right
afterwards so with that
I was presented a amendment by Senator
Perkins
on um
a change to a change to this
Bill 258 it's highly unusual the
um
the
Amendment would need to come from this
committee from the house
um if anyone wants to discuss the
amendment by the senator we're happy to
do that as discussion but at this point
in time I'm not planning on bringing
that forward
so it would take us back to the original
the bill uh 258 as presented
and
I would um
I recognize the vice chairman okay just
the question here on on the amendment
proposal meant by Senator Perkins if we
decided for some reason we liked this
amount we would have to have it
redrafted or rep or you know uh would
either yourself or somebody else you
would have to go to the OLS and have it
redrafted as a house and then is that
correct that that is my understanding
thank you Mr chairman
okay thank you
representative Jack did you want you
just made mention of that I confirmed
that with the with the house clerk
yesterday thank you for that
so I will is there any further
discussion on the Senate Amendment yes
represent Faulkner
I
I'm actually in favor of the bill as
originally presented but I understand
the Senate
amendment is designed to address some of
the concerns that they heard
in our hearing
and I believe that this is a
a reasonable way to proceed with this
and one which is likely to be acceptable
on the other side
if we pass it this way and I think that
it
it doesn't do what the original bill
had hoped to do in terms of
of the price of the of the real estate
but I think it does
allow us to preserve historic properties
with the uh with an agency that in fact
has some expertise in some
ability to um
to appreciate the historic nature of
some of these properties that are in dot
uh
possession of the present time so I I
think that we should consider this
amendment uh or the wording of this
amendment perhaps as it's renumbered as
a house Amendment and would be happy to
to move to to approve that at the time
that it is ready
so so if I unders if I understand
um
are are you suggesting representative
that you are willing to have this
drafted as as because we we can't
discuss it because it's it's not a house
if I understand representative Jack that
we can't discuss this because it's not a
house Amendment are you saying that you
want to go and have it drafted as a
house Amendment we recess again or would
you rather move to the
not do that and then move to the
discussion on uh 258 as non-damended
so the mechanism of whether we do that
today or whether we
postpone her the next time we could we
could meet
or whether we retain this and deal with
it in in the fall
um
all of those things that could work I I
just think that it's a mistake to
um
to Ita itl was built this time and they
would not support that I think
I mean the the issues that I think this
addresses and people were concerned
about selling any property at less than
market value
that's off the table with this amendment
people were concerned about
uh
about whether it was clear that we were
continuing to follow the same process
with the long-range planning and and
capital uh Capital programming committee
that's that's clarified in this
amendment
um
and so I mean I think that this was a
reasonable attempt to address the
concerns that we raised and I'm not
quite sure why
we wouldn't at least consider that
carefully because uh I think it was a
good faith effort to
to meet us halfway
and addressing the concerns that we
raised uh I think through the
questioning of the hearing
thank you representative Jack uh thank
you Mr chairman uh Nothing Stops us from
discussing the amendment uh the thing
that we couldn't do is adopt it as the
committee Amendment and then report the
bill as otpa with an s-numbered
amendment
we can't do that today but we could do
it once once we get a new number
well it is possible that we could we
could check with
um
with OLS on this and we could have an
amendment out today
maybe this morning
um I would I would rather conclude our
business for the committee today
and if if you're serious that this
amendment is something that you would
like to have
um to vote on then we could do that
but I would like to wrap up our
committee's business today
represent Cloutier uh yes I have a
question Mr chairman if for now we maybe
we could postpone discussion on the
amendment and get back to the main bill
because I have a question of Dot and Mr
Labonte if he is willing to answer it
please
okay all right I uh I'm gonna hear I'm
gonna hear further discussion from the
committee before I go there I do have
this question I'd like to ask if when we
get around to it thank you
I'm sorry we should have a motion
excuse me to discuss
ion
uh represent Mills is recognized for a
motion
thank you Mr chair Mr chairman of my
matter of SB 258 I'm moving expedient to
legislate second
motion made by Mills seconded by Jack
now we are open for discussion on Senate
Bill 258 and I will come is there I'll
come back to representative Cloutier
sure oh and I I would I would ask
I'm hoping for clarification questions
only on this I'm not hope I'm so I would
I'd like to keep the discussion focused
that's all I'm saying representative
okay please and I just want to check
about D.O.T owns the property and as
what are they do you have any plans for
it is that a proper question that's okay
thank you and I just want what are the
future plans uh d.o.t's future plans
thank you
could you could you repeat the question
okay yeah this property that is a main
focus of the Bill of house bill one of
the reasons it was sponsored by Senator
Perkins and the other sponsors in and I
believe this is in Newington and
basically
uh
this property right now I believe is
owned by due to have been owned for
several days I've heard 70 years and I'm
wondering
are there any plans by D.O.T to do
anything with it uh or I don't know even
if if I may miss share any plans to sell
it give whatever but I just was curious
what the future holds for this property
in regard especially in regards to Dot
and I I will first certify that I may
not be the best person to answer this
this question but my understanding is
the intent was to use this property uh
as mitigation
for the loss of the general Sullivan
Bridge
all right thank you so there's no
there's no plans right now to do
anything else right it's more for
mitigation
I haven't heard of anything other than
that
okay thank you Mr Robot Dave thank you
if I could while I have you there sir
um it's my understanding and
conversations that D.O.T during the
mitigation process had talked about a
sum of money uh to return this property
back to a better condition and my
understanding was that part of that
mitigation or part of that process was
some number in the area of a hundred
thousand dollars do you know anything
about that sir
I don't have great details on that but I
have heard a similar number being tossed
around them that we would contribute to
the preservation of the building so it's
my understanding that the stage intends
to preserve the building and was hoping
then that the ownership after it had and
I may be simplifying this
then the Hope was after that that then
the property could then be turned over
to the town which could turn it to the
uh which could then turn it to the
Historical Society to manage or to own
from that time forward but as we heard
in testimony for those that weren't here
that there was a disconnect when it when
time came where there was a Changing of
the Guard of the government or whatever
for the town they decided they didn't
want to do that
um the general Sullivan bridge for for
committee members that were not here
at least a couple terms ago
uh the the determination had been made
early on that the department was going
to either a save the structure and turn
it into a pedestrian Bikeway but then
discovered a later time that uh the
structure was failing to a point that
that didn't make sense
then they talked about building some new
structure for that purpose using the
pylons if that's the right term that
contains some historical significance
for millions of dollars to resemble in
some way
the old General Sullivan Bridge did not
meet favor with this committee and it
was a recommendation and a 10-year plan
to remove the superstructure so
unfortunately
in the Chairman's opinion
this building has become upon
for that
there was an attempt by legislation to
to have the town take it and that fell
through and my concern to Tinker with
this legislation as it is is not the
best use of time right now and that if
it was if this bill was to be removed
then it would allow members on this
committee possibly to work with DOT
would allow the Historical Society to
work with Dot and find another solution
that would work both for the town
and Dot so
um if the if the committee has further
questions of this gentleman I will take
it and if we don't we will go back to
discussion
yes please
oh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr Labonte for giving this qualification
[Music]
um the reason I wanted to ask the
question was I'd ask that other
Representatives when we were discussing
this bill before and it has to do with
the reversion
um that in fact there was a standard way
within the dot that if in fact you did
let's say sell it somehow or give it
whatever to uh
to the uh to the non-profit that if if
they fail for some some ways that there
was the the means just to take it back
state would just get it back without any
consideration of any money they put into
it or anything it would just revert back
to the state is something like that
correct that's correct if if so for
instance if we were selling a Wetlands
mitigation area saying we had 15 we
saved one of our projects impacted 15
Acres of wetlands so we were had an
obligation to preserve 15 Acres of
wetlands somewhere else
the idea would be that we would
seek to find a conservation group
that would take the property
heavily burdened with restrictions and a
conservation easement and a reverter
clause how the reverter Clause works if
the property ever falls out of the use
it was intended for title automatically
reverts back to the state no
compensation and as as we spoke before
this meeting uh it's it's Unique in that
uh under state law reverta Clauses for
for most parties except
non-profits and governmental entities it
it's illegal but there is an exception
for governmental entities and
non-profits
further questions I don't thank you
thank you both
further questions from D.O.T
okay yes please thank you thank you Mr
chairman no representative Mrs Lamonte
had
is your understanding that the dot and
historical have there been any
conversations between
yourselves and the Newington Personnel
who wish to preserve the property and
bring it to uh it's maybe its original
state
and go ahead
my understanding there has been
considerable conversation between uh
the historical society and
um
Jennifer rayshek who is the project
manager I haven't had that many except
here today but
I believe there have been yes okay thank
you and quick follow-up yes please this
was mention of a hundred thousand
dollars possibly uh is is that budge is
that budgeted is that set aside those
funds and I'm not privy to that
information I don't know if that's been
that there's a source for that fund at
this time or not okay thank you I just
heard the number
one further question
so the is is the proposal to
to the building itself in the land that
it sits on or is it the building itself
in Dover point
it is a is the proposal for the
Historical Society if if this
legislation were to pass you have a
building that's down there
and is it the footprint of just what's
around that and and maybe access in and
out because it would seem to me
that the state is still going to retain
the larger parcel which I refer to as
Dover point
so my understanding and I I again I
always was under the impression that we
were going to convey bloody point
with the building so I don't believe it
was just the footprint it was the entire
point
okay thank you
all right thank you for your time thank
you Mr Levante appreciate it thank you
Mr chairman
okay
um so we have a motion of I of itl
um and it has been second and I'm open
for further discussion at this time
yes represent villain
thank you Mr chairman
um at this point I'm still a little
reluctant to vote itl although I see the
logic behind it I'm much more
comfortable with a retain uh simply
because I think with the retain there's
still
then itl pretty much there's no the
pressure on uh the parties to act I
think is less that's all with the retain
there is this notion that if something
happens then perhaps we don't need to do
anything later on but if nothing happens
then maybe then we should reconsider the
bill so that's my I'm just expressing my
my thinking at the time uh and again I
know you folks have a lot more
experience on issues like this but
that's where I'm okay thank you all
right thanks representative
we'll support itl either I would
be willing to accept the retention as
well uh
just a reminder this is not just about
this one one property this is a change
in the procedure that affects
other similar situations that may occur
in the future
and I know that's occurred in the past
so it's uh it's not just this I mean
this is what motivated this particular
bill at this time
but here's an opportunity to
create a procedure whereby we can get
some public benefit out of these excess
properties in a way that takes it off
the out of the responsibility of dot
that I think we've heard that
they don't have the ability or the um
or the responsibility to
you know to do historic preservation or
to maintain Parks or other other things
that other
other agencies or other uh
that the groups might be able to do
better
um I just think that this is an
opportunity that we have now and that
it's a shame to
um kill it based upon one
project that we have in front of us now
thank thank you representative Faulkner
yes representative Newton yes um I do
agree that this bill is not site
specific and we keep referring to that
there's so many unknowns here
that um I think we ought to itl because
we don't know how many pieces of
property it's going to affect
we don't know
um any details with what this bill is
going to do and what they people are
going to be able to do with the property
and a lot of property that the state
gets from dot is by eminent domain and
how does that matter when they go to
dispose of it when they've got it by
eminent domain so until a either if
there's a problem with a specific piece
of property maybe somebody should bring
a bill forward dealing with just that
specific piece of property and make it
site specific or before this bill is
ready to go anywhere there's so much
information that has to be received and
and studied I would strongly recommend
we it almost Bill okay thank you
um
please know back and forth and I know
you sir go ahead
so there's a new Point brought up I mean
I think that
our job as a legislature is to set up
procedures that protect the public
interest or further the public interest
you know we leave the details of you
know exactly which what happens and what
properties
uh to the to the agencies and um you
know the procedure here that has checks
and balances we have
you know governor and executive Council
of the committee on I keep getting the
name wrong
long-range planning long-range Capital
planning and utilization committee
so those are the those are the steps
that we have placed
uh you know in this process now
for disposition of property we rely on
the agencies to
follow that process and justify
you know individual projects on an
individual basis so I think we've
retained that and I would be comfortable
with that as it is thank you any further
discussion yes please represent thank
you chairman uh jurors
it's important to understand for the
testimony that was uh we received last
month and that hot
early uh early summertime day that
the preservation and historical group
has put a lot of effort and uh Sweat
Equity into this into this matter a lot
of lobbying a lot of advocating uh and
it's
creating a mechanism to
uh help reduce the inventory of other
historical sites uh that the that the
dot has in their inventory I think is is
an important uh
is something important that it should be
taken up
so with that said I'm not too curious
about it yelling uh like to keep this
matter moving if and uh going forward
thank you thank you thank you represent
your opinion any further discussion
Mr chairman
I'm ready to call the rolls okay all
right sure sorry and we will see where
that goes so the motion motion's been
made by Mill seconded by Jack to itl uh
Senate Bill 258. we've had the
discussion if you're in favor of that
motion when your name is called just
signified by saying I or nay
yes or no with that the clerk will call
the roll
thank you Mr chairman
representative Cloutier
reluctantly yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative fadolfi yes
representative Newton yes
representative Kaczynski yes
representative Bowden
representative
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert
yes
representative Connor
representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar
hi
representative Faulkner no
representative Newman
no
representative Schultz no
representative Peterson
Representative vallone no
representative Juris no
Mr chair
man votes yes
shared a motion passes 13 to 5.
motion passes and I um we will put it on
the regular calendar
thank you Mr chairman with that we'll
call again the executive session on
Senate Bill 258 and at this point in
time that is our last bill that's before
this committee if I could get you just
to hold a moment I want to send a
congratulations card uh signed by those
that would be willing to sign a card
I want to thank you for your time and
attention the only thing Mr chairman the
driveway permit Bill the Senate amended
on if we can take that up the Senate
Amendment today or that'll discuss it
further among the committee by email
that is still in a little bit of flush
okay I just wanted to be because I'm
members are talking about it
the I spoke to the um that is on the um
House Bill what's the number on that
it's uh House Bill 296. 296 that went to
the Senate and was amended uh has been
brought back and I had conversations
this morning with the uh Prime sponsor
and
um he is still up in the air whether
that makes sense I know that it's going
to be our committee bill but I was
looking to see where the prime sponsor
felt on that and we'll discuss that
amongst the committee I don't think we
have to have a formal meeting to do that
and I don't believe it'll be brought in
this this
um Thursday okay and that as well as the
amendment to the capital budget right I
mean we discussed that we'll discuss
that later the um on the amendment to
the capital budget I think you all have
seen that there was a there was a
correction or two made on it which was I
believe one was a lapse funding movement
um and one was to change
the purchase of the building down here
from
from if my understanding is correct from
being
overseen by the Department of Education
was then changed to be overseen by uh
Public Works
our public works department
and both the um
the commissioner of education and Public
Works was in favor of that
so my my having attended many of it the
vice chairman some other members were
there from time to time
they took our bill and accepted
99.9 percent 99 of everything we
submitted and repeatedly thanked the
committee for the hard work so it made
their job much easier so
I don't and if anyone wants to discuss
that but I don't I don't see a reason
why we wouldn't concur with that bill
also
further question
okay thank you Mr chairman for those
updates okay so we we are we stand in
recess and I will um
I will go get that card if you could
just hold on that
foreign